MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Today, we're talking
about Google
Cloud's Architecture
Framework, streaming
analytics, and Cloud OnBoard.
I'm Mark Mirchandani,
and welcome to "This Week
in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
Google Cloud's
Architecture Framework
offers best practices and
implementation guidance
for your application design.
From operational excellence
to security, privacy
and compliance, reliability,
and cost optimization,
this framework provides
strategies, recommendations,
and design questions
that will help
you build the architecture
you need to succeed.
Google Cloud is bringing
together all of our streaming
technologies into one solution.
Streaming analytics makes
data more organized,
useful, and accessible from
the instant it's generated.
Built on Pub/Sub,
Dataflow, and BigQuery,
our streaming solution
provides the resources
you need to ingest,
process, and analyze
fluctuating volumes of real
time data for real time business
insights.
Check out the features
that make this possible,
and then build your
own streaming pipeline.
Now could be a great
time to learn from home.
You can tune in on
May 19 and 20 to watch
instructors on
Google Cloud OnBoard
break down what it takes
to migrate to Google Cloud
and explain the basics of
Google Kubernetes Engine.
After the sessions,
you'll have a chance
to test what you've learned by
participating in hands-on labs
and challenges with the
Cloud Hero online challenge.
Have you ever wondered how
Google Cloud technical solution
engineers solve some
of your support cases?
Or maybe you're just a
fan of detective stories.
Either way, we've got a fun
and informative deep-dive
into how one of our
engineers solved a DNS
problem for a customer.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.